earlier this week I invited a local
clown on our show to share some of his
grievances about the movie it and I'll
be honest he came out here and he didn't
do a terrific job okay
I felt bad for him so when I just just
on behalf of the clown community I want
to give this guy one more chance please
welcome back to the show
butterscotch the clown let's go
[Applause]
it's uh really nice to see you
butterscotch it's great to be back and
to all the kids out there watching take
it from butterscotch real clowns are
sweet and fun and we would never dream
of eating a child
okay well that's that's a guess that's a
good reminder to kiss thank you very
much butterscotch that's great you know
what if I'm being honest I have dreamed
about eating children a lot actually but
remember kids you can't go to jail for
dreaming
and be honest that was weird okay
butterscotch how do you feel about all
the clowns that are protesting the movie
yet how do you feel about that I said
good for them we need to change minds
and hearts
that's why I've started my own campaign
to remind people clowns are here to make
you happy not scared or dead
check out this poster I made let's check
it out I didn't like that butterscotch
check out this other one to show how
inclusive we clowns are okay
there's always room yeah I've been
putting these up wherever kids are their
schools their playgrounds their bedrooms
you know what you're doing is not really
helping well maybe this will help
hey Scott jealous what is that you made
out of balloons
I made a balloon wife isn't she
beautiful yeah I guess yeah she's even
better than a flesh wife because she
won't stop having sex with me just
because I need to wear a sleep apnea
mask to bed my life Allison
I'm not butter Scott
butterscotch I'm not I'm not sure any
children anywhere are gonna be excited
about your balloon wife okay well here's
something no kid can resist a magic
trick who wants to see a magic trick
well things I just need it's one the
volunteer from the audience
gonna grant somebody new shirt here be
my volunteer come on give them a round
of applause
okay I need you to get down and hold
that bowling pin really steady all at
the base the bottom of it there make
sure it doesn't move at all okay
now who wants to see me make this
bowling pin disappear please and here we
go that's enough butterscotch that's
enough okay that you can go but do not
tell anyone what is transpired here or I
will kill you and eat you
in conclusion I'd like to do my funny
little clown dance for everyone here it
yakamoto
[Music]
okay yeah but no no no butter butter
butter Scott's the clown everybody
[Applause]
you